everyone loves a good april fools joke
but where's the invisible line of
acceptability and who dares cross it
apparently frostbite engine will a
series of tweets making fun of the we
use technical capabilities have been
denounced by EA CEO Peter Moore who has
called them unacceptable I'm mark Walton
and this is a game spot news update
battlefield publisher Electronic Arts
has deleted a string of tweets that
derided the Wii U for being underpowered
system the jabs were focused around the
fact that EAS proprietary engine
frostbite cannot run on Wii U the tweets
have since been removed with this being
the internet they live on in glorious
screencapped form good news we have
finally fixed and optimized our neck
home uses quantum entanglement for zero
latency connections exclusively on hash
Wii U frostbite willpower hash half-life
3 coming out 2014 patch wii u exclusive
and frostbite now runs on the hash wii u
since it is the most powerful gen4
platform our renderer is now optimized
from Mario and Zelda ea's Peter more
since issued a statement on the tweets
via his Twitter account saying our
apologies to partners at Nintendo
America and fans at frostbite engines
poor attempt to April Fool's not
condoned by EA unacceptable and stupid
EA supported the Wii U at launch with
games like new to speed most wanted mass
effect 3 fifa 13 and madden NFL 13
however the publisher is no longer
working on any Ryu titles whatsoever by
comparison EA supported the original Wii
with 78 titles through its lifetime the
Wii U has been the butt of many and
online whimsy since its launch but with
frostbites tweets a step too far let us
know in the comments below and until the
next PR Twitter disaster keeper gamespot